despite the Brian Williams lying scandal
the NBC Nightly News led in the ratings
last week commander sting the right
thing yeah although I should note those
figures were reported by Brian Williams
I heard there's a rumor that NBC is
going to have Tom Brokaw fill in
temporarily as NBC News anchor yeah when
asked why Brokaw a network spokesperson
said because the only other NBC icon we
have from the 80s is Bill Cosby
what else is going on hey Louisiana
Governor Bobby Jindal is as
indian-american and people are saying
his new official portrait makes him look
more white yeah yeah they didn't change
his skin color they just painted him at
a hockey game riding a Segway weird
which is hard to do in Louisiana yeah
exactly
this weekend the movie Fifty Shades of
Grey opens now the movie lasts 125
minutes unless you say the safe word
[Laughter]
now some hardware stores are stocking up
on rope and duct tape
in anticipation this is true hardware
stores are actually stocking up on rope
and duct tape in anticipation of the
movie Fifty Shades of Grey yeah because
apparently tying your boyfriend up is
the only way to get him to go see these
guys over here oh that's why and your
girlfriend you like I'm not seeing that
sex movie yeah no way Jose
we're going to that environmental
documentary what else is going on more
fallout from the Grammys it's been
reported that Beyonce wore ten million
dollars worth of jewels to the Grammys
ten million dollars yeah when asked why
Beyonce said I didn't want to bring the
good stuff quite wealthy you know this
is crazy it's been reported that
Samsung's new Smart TVs the heavy Smart
TVs could be listening to your
conversations yes the televisions are
only listening to us because they too
are getting bored with Downton Abbey
thing is going nowhere what are they
saying
two members of the village people are in
court to battle over who wrote some of
their big hits like YMCA yes it's the
landmark case of cop vs. Indian chief
this is a big case
you